Now I'd like to introduce today's
featured presenter, Pamela Hinds.
Pamela Hinds is a Professor
of Management Science and
Engineering in the School of
Engineering at Stanford University.
The Director of the Center for
Work Technology and Organization, and
Faculty Director of
the School of Engineering,
Global Engineering Program for students.
Pamela studies the effect
of technology on groups.
She's contributed extensive research on
the dynamics of geographically distributed
work teams, particularly those
spanning national boundaries.
She explored issues of culture,
language, emotion and conflict, and
the role of site visits and
promoting trust and collaboration.
Most recently, she has been exploring the
relationship between national culture and
work practices especially
innovation practices.
Pamela has also been exploring the
relationship between national culture and
technology use.
And is interested in the design
of collaborative technologies for
use across national boundaries.
Now I'll turn it over to Pamela.
>> Okay, as Sherry said,
I'm going to be talking a little bit today
about Us vs Them, overcoming
differences to inspire collaboration.
Many of you are probably working in
teams that are spending a variety of
different kinds of boundaries.
Working with people who are, maybe in
a different location, even in a different
country, from a different discipline,
in a different organization, and so forth.
And all of those differences can really
lead to positive outcomes, but can also be
challenging for people, and that's
what we're going to talk about today.
So one premise, and this is something that
was mentioned by new article by Forbes.
Diversity is a key driver for
innovation, and
that is something that is
generally believed to be true.
What we've seen over the last
couple of decades is that more and
more organizations are looking to
diversity as a way to bring in different
perspectives, and
drive higher levels of innovation.
There was a survey that was done by Forbes
of C-level executives around the globe.
And they asked them, does a diverse,
inclusive workforce, is it crucial to
encouraging different perspectives and
ideas that drive innovation?
48% of the people surveyed strongly agreed
with that statement, 37% somewhat agreed.
So a very large percentage of the
respondents really do believe that having
a diverse and inclusive workforce helps
bring in these different perspectives and
increase the innovation
potential of an organization.
So, another quick poll.
In your opinion, does working across
boundaries actually increase innovation?
Well, I've got 10 seconds for
you to complete the poll.
If you don't think it really helps at all,
you could answer one or A.
If you think that it's really crucial for
innovation,
you can answer E or five, very much.
So the poll has ended.
And, we're going to take just a few
seconds to pull up the results of that.
Okay, here we go.
And what we're seeing is
just like the executives
that were polled around the globe.
Many people seem to think that it probably
leads to higher levels of innovation.
Or even you've got 127 respondents
that said that it's very important,
it very much leads to innovation.
So let's look at what the research shows.
It actually depends.
Does working across boundaries
increase innovation?
Some of the research suggests
that there are real benefits.
And some of it suggests that, in fact,
we're not seeing higher
levels of innovation.
There's work done by
Lee Fleming at Harvard.
And he looked in particular at diversity
in team members' disciplines or
backgrounds, their functional expertise.
And then mapped that against
the value of innovation they
were producing in these teams.
And there are two really important things
that you'll see if you look closely
at this graph.
One is, that the average
value of innovation actually
goes down as you get more
diversity on the teams.
So that's a little bit surprising
given that we really think and
hope that higher levels of diversity
should actually lead to more innovation.
But the other thing that's really
interesting about this slide
is that the only time you see
breakthrough innovations.
The only time that you
see really high level of
innovation is when you have
this diversity in the teams.
And what this tells us, and actually a lot
of research that's been done on a variety
of different kinds of diversity,
including ethnic diversity,
gender diversity, diversity in
national background, and so forth.
All of that research shows that
oftentimes, you do see a decrease in
innovation, and a decrease in performance
when you have a lot of diversity in teams.
But, it's also an opportunity for
really high levels of innovation.
But the challenge is managing those teams.
It takes a little bit more effort and
attention to manage teams with
higher levels of diversity.
And a couple of elements.
So first of all,
we've got a lot of different kinds of
diversity on the left side of the slide.
And what really has to happen,
but what has to be managed in
order to get the innovation
that a team is looking for,
first is you have to actually
get the information out.
The benefits of diversity is you
have these different perspectives.
You have different kinds of information
that people have access to.
But sometimes it's a little bit
challenging to get all that information
out in a way that it can be used
toward innovation and in the team.
And then the second element is once
you've got the information out,
you see that people are seeing
these from different perspectives.
How do you then integrate
those different perspectives?
How do you bring that together so
that you're developing something
new as a result of it.
So let's dive a little bit down into
the first one, getting information out.
To achieve their innovation potential,
teams need to first be able to
get the information on the table.
If you don't share these perspectives,
then what's the point of working
across boundaries at all?
Couple different things
that have to happen here.
One is it really helps if the team
has a learning orientation.
And that's something that can
be influenced by the culture of
the organization, influenced by
the leader of the organization.
And people really need to
want to learn from others.
They want to believe that learning these
different perspectives is actually going
to help them to be more successful
in achieving their goals.
They also need to anticipate that there
are going to be alternative view points
when they go into a meeting.
It turns out that if people walk into
a meeting knowing that they're going
to hear very different view points,
they come with a different mindset.
And are better able to process
those different viewpoints.
So letting people know that that's
valued and that they should expect that.
And that's also really important
that people feel valued and safe.
People will not share their different
perspectives if they feel like their
perspective is not going to be
appreciated, heard, and so forth.
And then finally, it just takes more time.
When everybody shares the same
perspective, you've got a lot of common
ground, it's really easy to
talk quickly through things.
But when people have really
different perspectives,
often much more explanation
is needed in order for
people to understand all those different
view points and that just takes time.
And then once you got the information out,
the next hurdle is integrating
this diverse information.
People need to understand the relevance
of what it is they've heard.
And if people are coming from
really different perspectives,
it can be challenging to see how
what somebody else is offering
fits the way that you're thinking about
the problem that you're working on.
And sometimes it can just
be hard to relate to and
make sense of what
somebody else is saying.
A couple things that
are really helpful in that.
One is, again, it takes time.
There needs to be more conversation,
more discussion about these different
perspectives in order
to see the relevance.
In order to figure out where
there is common ground in
the different viewpoints that
are being brought together.
And that helps to overcome what's
called a representational gap.
Which is that when people particularly
are coming from different
disciplinary perspectives they often have
different ways that they have been
trained to represent a problem.
And again, if you can take the time for
people to really articulate how they're
representing the problem, how they're
prioritizing different elements of it,
then that can help people to find
opportunities for common ground.
So what we're going to focus on
today is the us versus them dynamic
that interferes with
all of these processes.
So that's one of the things
that as leaders,
you can work on addressing in your teams.
And that's effective whether
you're cross organizational,
cross functional, cross geography,
cross cultural, and so forth.
It turns out, that the us vs them dynamic
that you see in these teams is one
of the most pervasive problems that
we see in cross-boundary teams.
It's one of these things that is just so
human.
We have this natural tendency
to subgroup into different groups
that are similar to ourselves.
And this is something that just
naturally happens in these teams.
And I'll talk a little bit today about why
that happens and what we can do about it.
But first, I'm going to ask
you a couple of questions and
then I'll just wait a few seconds.
You might want to just write
down a couple of your answers.
So each of these, I'd like you to answer
why you think this might have happened.
So the first one is a colleague
that you're working with in
Amsterdam regularly gets up and
leaves your teleconferences
early at 4:50 PM their time,
instead of 5 o'clock PM.
So just make a couple of notes
about why they might be doing this.
All right, and
then the next one a coworker from
marketing gives you
misleading information.
Why might that have happened?
Again, just take a few seconds
to jot down a couple notes.
All right, the third one is a colleague
from another company that you're
working with sends you
an analysis that's badly flawed.
Why might that have happened?
Okay, so for each of these,
there are many possible responses.
For the colleague in Amsterdam,
you might've said that they had a train
to catch and it only leaves hourly and
they need to get home to their family.
You might have said that they're lazy,
that they're uncommitted.
These are all answer that I've
gotten before to this question.
For the second one, you might say
that the person is incompetent.
So they gave you misleading information.
Or they've got another
agenda that they're working.
You might have also said that they just
have a different way of explaining things
because they're from a different field.
For the third one,
you might have said that the person
misunderstood the request, or they didn't
have the information that they needed.
So these are all what
we call attributions,
they're ways of explaining
things when things go wrong.
And we are making attributions all day,
every day.
We're making judgements about why it
is that something happened the way
that it did.
So there's a whole theory in
psychology around attribution theory.
And what attribution theory suggests is
that there are two different types of
attributions that we can make.
We can make what are called
dispositional attributions and
those are attributions
that are about the person.
So if you found yourself writing
things like they're lazy,
uncommitted, incompetent,
anything of that sort.
Those would be dispositional or
personal attributions about
why something went wrong.
But then there's also
situational attributions.
And situational attributions
are attributing what it is
that went wrong to
characteristics of the situation.
So if you wrote things like they
need to catch the train, or
they didn't have the information that
they should have been given and so forth,
those are more situational attributions.
And as you can imagine,
the situational attributions tend
to be a little bit more generous.
The thing is that we tend
to lean toward making
more dispositional
attributions in general.
And the reason that we make more
dispositional attributions, or
personal attributions is because we
don't have as much information about why
people are doing what they're doing.
We have a lot of information about
why we're doing what we're doing.
But not so much with other people.
And then if they are in a different
location or in a different country,
if they're in a different culture,
in a different firm, we have even less
information to help us explain why it
is they're doing what they're doing.
So there's a natural tendency
in these cross-boundary
teams to actually make more
of these kind of harsh,
personal kinds of attributions and that
really fuels this us versus them dynamic.
There's an ingroup bias as well which
I'll talk a little bit about in a minute.
So what can you do as leaders?
When you see this us versus
them dynamic and I have to say,
it is almost inevitable.
You probably will see it, but
you can also do things to reduce
the likelihood of it showing up.
What are those?
There are three things
I'm going to talk about.
One is shared identity.
One is trust and then the third
is psychological safety, and
these are all really intertwined.
They're all mutually
supportive of one another.
So there's not one that's more
important than the other.
You could actually start at
any one of these three and
that would help to erode some
of the us versus them dynamics
that you are seeing or
that could happen in your team.
So we'll start with shared identity.
This is just some research that I
did a while back with Mark Mortensen
who's at INSEAD in France.
We were looking at globally
distributed teams and
one of the things that we found
was that having a shared identity,
significantly reduced the amount of
conflict that occurred on these teams.
And in particular,
something called affective conflict and
that's where it really gets personal.
So having a shared identity
really help to reduce those
negative attributions about
the person in particular and
there's a ton of research in
social psychology that looks at
the importance of shared identity,
and having a vision.
This is something that you can
do in your teams as leaders.
If people have a shared vision,
they believe that they
are working toward a common goal.
That they are all in it together.
That they are interdependent and
have to rely on one another in order to
be successful at achieving their goals,
then you see a shared identity
develop very rapidly, quite strongly.
And the us versus them dynamics
can virtually disappear,
if people are really focused
on a strong shared vision.
Now, the trick is that you can start
this at the beginning of a project.
People completely bought in.
Everybody's really aligned with the vision
and see how other's fit in, and
why they need to work together.
But when you're working across boundaries,
it erodes more rapidly.
If you are not co-located,
people begin to make sense of
the vision in different ways.
If you are from different disciplines,
you may start to prioritize
one element over the other.
So, it's something that has to be
completely or continuously revisited and
reinforced in order to ensure that that
is still in place on an ongoing basis.
So now, we're going to talk
a little bit about trust.
And again, these are intertwined.
So it turns out that if you got
a stronger shared identity,
what comes with that is more trust.
And if you got more trust,
it's easier to build a shared identity.
So with trust, I'd like you to bring
to mind somebody that you really trust.
So just for a second, think of somebody.
And then again, just jot down a couple of
characteristics that lead
you to trust this person.
I'll give you a few seconds
to write those down.
So you might have written a whole host
of things like they care about you.
They always do what they say.
They know what they're doing.
I'm sure there's a whole variety
of things that you wrote down.
What I'm going to show you now
is definition of trust and
then what some of the different elements
are that have been found to compose trust,
and trustworthiness.
So trust is assured reliance
on the character, ability or
truth of someone or something.
Somebody in which you put confidence and
a more research-oriented definition.
The willingness to be vulnerable to
the actions of another person based on
the expectation that,
that other person will perform a
particular action that's important to you,
the trustor, irrespective of your ability
to monitor or control that person.
So there's a couple of things I
want to pull out of that definition.
One is trust is really
about being vulnerable.
So it's only really trust if you've
ended up in a situation where you
actually depend upon that person and
you trust them to actually do it is you
need done, and they've said they would do.
And importantly, it's irrespective of the
ability to monitor or control the person.
Some people say that you trust,
but control.
The truth is they're different things.
And oftentimes, when you are especially
geographically distributed,
it's really difficult to monitor control.
So trust becomes even more important in
these situations and that's also true when
you're crossing other kinds of boundaries,
when you're working across firm.
It's true when you're working across
disciplines where you actually
don't have enough knowledge of that
discipline to evaluate whether or
not what they're doing is appropriate or
correct,
then you really are vulnerable their
actions and trust is required.
So there are three elements of trust
that have been identified in research.
One is benevolence.
So benevolence is really about whether or
not the person is caring and
concerned about you.
Benevolence at the extreme is
they will do something for
you even if they have to make
a sacrifice for themselves.
So if you said that I trust this person,
because they care about me.
I know they'll do the right thing,
then that's really benevolence.
The next one is ability and
this is something that people
often don't think about.
But particularly in a work context,
we have to believe that people
can actually do what it is they
need to do in order to trust them.
They have to have the technical skills.
They have to have the marketing savvy in
order for us to trust that they're going
to be able to fulfill their obligations
to us and then there's integrity.
An integrity is really about reliability,
predictability, honor.
Do they have a code by which they
are operating that you can count on.
It doesn't necessarily need to be the same
code as yours, but you can count on it.
You know what it is to expect of them and
the three of these compose trust and
trustworthiness.
A couple of things that are sort of
interesting to know is that different
people value the different
elements differently.
So you may be somebody where your whole
list was all about benevolence, but
somebody else might really
think it's all about ability.
And they really want to work with
people that are the most capable and
they don't worry too
much about the others.
So it's not a bad conversation
to have to understand and
what people are really valuing,
and to use that as a lens to
evaluate whether or
not you can assess them as trustworthy.
So if we're talking about cross-boundary
teams, this is our next poll.
Is there generally less trust
on cross-boundary teams?
Or more trust?
So we'll take about ten seconds for
you to answer this poll.
And this can be any kind
of cross-boundary team.
The poll has ended, and we're going to
wait just a couple of seconds while
we get the results of
the poll to see whether or
not people think there's going to be more
or less, or no difference on these teams.
All right, well, this is interesting.
So most people,
231 of the respondents thought that
there would be less trust on
these cross-boundary teams.
A handful thought it would
be about the same, and
a few people thought you actually could
end up with more trust on these teams.
So we thought that there would
be less trust on these teams and
set out to do a research study to see
the extent to which that was true.
And what we found was, in fact,
it was about the same.
So these, in particular,
were geographically co-located versus
distributed teams and
they were construction engineering teams.
So we had some architects,
some people in construction,
and variety of other disciplines in there.
So they were geographically distributed
and also from different disciplines.
But as you can see, we looked at month
one when they formed these teams and
month three and
it didn't really seem to matter very much.
So that kind of surprised us and
we dug a little deeper into
the data to see what was going on.
And what we saw was that on the collocated
teams, it was much more volatile.
So we ended up with dramatic
increases in trust, but
also dramatic decreases in trust.
And we think that had a lot to do with
the fact that when you're colocated,
you can actually see
people's' behaviors more.
You've got more information about whether
or not they are caring toward other
people, whether or not they are capable,
whether or not they do have integrity.
So we got increases and decreases as
people adjusted their level of trust.
In the distributive teams,
there was a lot less adjustment.
People started with a certain level
of trust at the beginning and
that was maintained throughout.
And looking at this a little bit more
closely what we saw was in collocated
teams, people paid attention
to the behavior, whether or
not people were following through,
their team members were following through.
And that affected whether or
not they were trustworthy.
And then that affected their
trust later in the process.
But in the distributed teams,
it started with perceived trustworthiness.
So very quickly people,
team members evaluated whether or
not somebody was trustworthy.
Then when they saw their behaviors,
they looked at those behaviors through
that lens of being trustworthy or not.
And then the attributions
were aligned with whether or
not they thought they were trustworthy.
And that affected trust
later on in the game.
So basically what this shows
is that establishing trust
really early in these
cross-boundary teams is crucial.
Because once it gets established,
the updating doesn't happen as dynamically
as it does on teams where there's a lot
more similarity and in particular when
people are collocated and have more
information about what people are doing.
So now we'll talk a little bit
about psychological safety, and
psychological safety is pretty
closely related to trust.
When you have more trust people
feel more safe psychologically,
and if you've got more psychological
safety, people are more trusting and
then the same thing with shared identity.
So psychological safety is
defined as a shared belief.
That's held by a team that the team is
safe for interpersonal risk taking.
This was an idea that was
developed by Amy Edmondson
at Harvard Business School
about twenty years ago.
There's been a ton of research on
psychological safety now establishing it.
As an important predictor
of team success and
particularly team innovation in
many places around the globe.
The basic idea here is
that people need to feel
safe sharing unpopular opinions.
Sharing knowledge, pointing out errors,
talking about mistakes that they've made.
It's basically an environment where
people feel like they are supported
by one another, and
there's not competition and
undermining going on by
members of the team.
So this is really crucial for
innovation in general and
particularly when you have
cross-boundary teams.
Psychological safety has been
shown to have significant impacts
on team performance,
on team problem solving and
particularly on learning and
innovation in teams.
And the interesting thing about
psychological safety is that it is
significantly affected by leader behavior.
That is one of the number
one predictors of whether or
not you'll have psychological safety,
is whether or
not the leader sort of sets the tone for
people to feel comfortable.
And again,
this has been done around the globe.
For example,
when leaders are open, accessible,
available to the people that they're
working with when they model
psychological safe behaviors, they
talk about mistakes that they've made.
They don't punish or
degrade people who have failed, but
really use that as a learning opportunity,
all of that behavior
by leaders leads to higher
levels of psychological safety.
And then, one additional practice I wanted
to share with you is team reflection.
So this can really help increase
psychological safety, as well as trust.
Where teams actually take 15 minutes
on occasion, maybe once a month or so,
to just reflect on how things are going.
Are they happy with their performance?
Are they happy with the process?
Are they happy with the way
that they're working together?
How might they improve their
ability to work together?
What are the strategies that they might
use in order to get better performance and
feel better about the process.
The interesting thing is it's sort
of like exercising regularly.
Even though you know it's good for you,
it doesn't always happen spontaneously.
People are really busy.
People are focused on the work
that they need to get done.
So it is really important that
a context be set for this to happen.
Where the leader, for example, says,
we are going to do this every month or
at some best by interval.
And time is actually made for it.
Reflective teams are more effective, but
you gotta make the commitment to that.
So just to sort of summarize
what we've talked about here.
Shared identity is a really
powerful condition for teens.
And that can be established
With a common vision,
making sure that people understand
their interdependences,
what it is they're working on together,
and continue to reinforce that over time.
With trust,
be vigilant against harsh attributions.
One of the ways to do this is to
always seek clarifying information.
If you find yourself making
harsh attributions about
particularly people in these
cross boundary situations.
Or you see team members
making harsh attributions,
personal kinds of attributions.
It's always good to ask the question,
well what else might be going on here.
What other information
could I get to help me
to understand what really is
the reason behind this behavior.
And that can really defuse the harsh
attributions and increase trust.
And then, we forget psychological
safety a leader can be a role
model by discussion mistakes,
being respectful of others,
not punishing failure, expression kind
concern about employees and so forth.
And then team reflection
can help with all of these.
All right, so
to wrap up on cross-boundary teaming,
we've talked about some of the core
issues that occur when people are working
across these boundaries and
these us versus them dynamics emerge.
And hopefully I've convinced you
that you can sustain higher levels
of performance and
innovation by fostering, shared identity,
psychological safety and
higher levels of trust.
So thank you very much,
we've got some time for questions.
I'm going to turn it over to Sherry,
who is going to facilitate that process.
>> So let's see, so
from our participants, here's one.
What's your advice for teams Pamela that
have very different business styles, and
some of which may be cultural?
Here's an example, specifically
we work with a team in Frankfort
that's very cautious, methodical,
and adverse to failure.
Our scientists and engineers in San Jose
are more aggressive with innovation and
willing to accept small failures
to advance more quickly to a final
successful design.
How do they compromise?
>> Right,
yeah that's a really good question.
Is something that I talk about much
more extensively in the course?
The cultural differences and
in particular, differences in practices.
One of the things that I found in
my research where we've looked at
innovation and innovation practices
in different parts of the world,
is that there are different
approaches to innovation.
And in fact what we've found is that some
of the things like rapid iteration that
is so touted in the Silicon Valley
in the US culture
actually can have negative effect
in some other cultural context.
So I think it's really important
to know that what works for
innovation in one culture may
not work in another culture.
And I think the first thing to do is to
figure out what the best practices are for
innovation in the culture in which you're
working, because it may not be the same.
And then figure out how to,
I don't know if you want to compromise or
if you want to allow multiple
practices to co-exist
in order to get the most
out of different people.
Or maybe try out different practices and
see what that generates.
But I do think that it's really
important to start with the practice and
understand how those are differ
in different cultures and
not only national cultures but
also in functional cultures.
Different professions have very,
very different practices.
And really understanding those can help
to figure out how to work together,
and achieve high level of innovation
in a united way, thank you.
>> We have another participant asking,
do you think trust needs
evidence to be built?
>> Yeah,
that's really an interesting question.
There is some research that talks
about something called swift trust.
So swift trust does not
need evidence to be built.
Swift trust happens because you
got information that gives you
confidence that this
person should be trusted.
So, for example,
it's somebody that's been recommended to
you by somebody else that you trust a lot.
Or they've gone to a top tier
university and gotten good grades.
Well, then you might automatically
think that they're going
to be a really competent, capable person.
So there's a lot of information that we
look to in our environment to figure out
whether or not somebody should be trusted.
And we can look at that evidence
to build this swift trust.
Or maybe somebody's licensed
in a particular field,
so there is this with trust.
It doesn't last forever, though.
As you are working with somebody,
you are always getting evidence
about trust and trustworthiness.
So yes, certainly over time,
you do need evidence
in order to I wouldn't say
determine your level of trust but
adjust your level of initial
trust that was formed.
The challenge is that we,
the way that we process that
information can sometimes be biased
because we don't have full information and
these attributions are at play.
So we may see evidence of something.
For example,
somebody not delivering a report on time.
And we may then have our trust
lowered as a result of that,
when in fact there might have
been something else going on.
So really important that
you know the trust and
the attributions are really intertwined.
And one of the things that I really
encourage on these cross-boundary
teams is to give people
the benefit of the doubt.
To trust them first, and then figure out
what it is that might have been going on.
>> Great, here's one,
building trust with an overseas team
in Europe has become very challenging.
The flow of information is one way.
I don't get any information
back from them.
What are the options this
participant might have?
>> Yeah, that's another really
good question, tough situation.
And it's not uncommon to
have these situations where
there's not enough
communication between teams or
sub-teams that are located in
different parts of the globe.
I guess a couple of things I'd try.
One is that's more likely to happen.
If there isn't a strong
sense of interdependence,
if they really rely on you for
their success
then they should be in contact
with you more frequently.
So that, there's something
going on there potentially.
So that might mean that
there's not the kind of shared
division that needs to
be present in order for
that team to function as
effectively as they need to.
The other thing that can happen
is people just got really busy.
I've seen a lot of teams where there's
just not very much communication
from one Location and it's because there's
a lot going on that we don't even
know about at that location.
So it's another case where I think
it's always good to if you can,
send a text message or pick up the phone
during their day time hours and
just check in with somebody that you feel
like you've got a good rapport with.
And say, hey you know, just checking in,
you know what's going on over there.
Wanted to see if there's
anything we should know about,
what's happening in your world there
right now, in order to get a better
sense of why they might not be
responding as quickly as you'd hope.
>> Sounds like good advice.
Another person is asking you to clarify
what team reflection could look like.
>> Right, yeah,
so team reflection, oftentimes it's
just a really informal process.
So getting team members in the room and
just asking the question,
how are things going?
Or getting in the room either virtually or
in person.
It's good to have it happen in person,
but oftentimes that is not possible.
Better to have it on video than just
audio when you're doing these kinds
of reflections because there's additional
cues where you can see people's facial
expressions and gestures can be really
useful in a reflective kind of activity.
And you might want to use a process where
people are able to write down
on Post-It notes or something
what they think is going well and
where they think the opportunities are for
improvement in either their performance or
in their group process.
And then talk through those.
And ideally have an open
conversation where people
can articulate what it is that is working
for them and is not working for them.
And then identify some strategies.
What can we do in the next
week in order to help us
improve on this particular element?
And again, having a really open,
not rushed kind of contact.
And if it's done regularly,
people get accustomed to doing it.
>> You've talked a lot
about building trust early.
We're getting several
questions on how do you
back up from a team that's
become dysfunctional.
So how do you rebuild trust when it's been
shattered and respect is nonexistent?
>> Yeah, that is really challenging.
I think my inclination would be to go with
one of the other two boxes on the chart.
Psychological safety has also probably
been undermined on that team.
And people may have lost sight
of why they need one another and
why they want to build trust and
work together.
So I would probably start with
the shared identity piece and
really helping people to see why
this whole group is in the room,
why they depend upon each other and
why it's really important to
rebuild the bonds that they have.
And I think it's important to name it,
too, to say, look, trust has broken down.
A whole variety of reasons for
why that might've happened.
Let's use some techniques
to rebuild that and create a higher
level of psychological safety.
And again, both with this question and
the previous question,
the leader modeling is
really important in this.
So the leader saying we've
had some breakdowns in trust.
I hold some of the responsibility for
this.
I want to rebuild it.
And with psychological safety,
the leader showing some
vulnerability, talking about mistakes so
forth.
All of that openness and
it's really challenging because when
trust isn't there, the openness is
hard and it can be misinterpreted.
So you kind of have to take baby
steps in order to help rebuild and
sometimes it does help to get a
facilitator in if trust is really damaged.
It can help to get a mediator in that
can help facilitate those conversations.
>> Here's a question that's
addressing language issues.
I'm an American but
my team is located in Brazil.
While my Portuguese is usually adequate,
there are times when I sense frustration
on the part of my colleagues when
I ask them to repeat things.
How would you advise team members
to be more effective communicators
when the primary language used for
business isn't their first language?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
Language is really challenging and
that's another segment
that's covered in the course,
language challenges,
both professional languages and
national languages.
Couple things on that,
one is that we need to recognize, and
this isn't always recognized,
that fluent does not mean fluent.
When somebody is doing
business in a language that is
their non-native language,
it is more challenging for them.
It takes more cognitive effort.
There might be vocabulary that
they don't have access to.
They may have an accent,
they mispronounce things and so forth.
And oftentimes, native speakers,
and this is particularly true of
native English speakers, in part because
of the way our cultures operate as well.
We tend not to be as patient
as we could be with that.
So I think part of it is just
building an appreciation on both
sides for what it means and
what the experience
is of somebody who is having to
operate in a non-native language.
And what the experience is of
somebody who is a native language
speaker of the chosen language,
the lingua franca and
having to sort of slow
down their processes
in order to work
effectively in those teams.
So, in particular, with your question,
I think part of it is just
letting the team members that
you're working with in Brazil know
that you are trying really hard,
that you are attempting
to speak Portuguese.
But you don't have the same
level of fluency and
that you really appreciate
their patients in
allowing you to occasionally
not be as articulate
as you would be in your native language.
So a lot of this is about
perspective taking and
understanding what
people are experiencing.
>> So
you were talking about harsh attribution.
One of our participants is saying they see
issues of harsh attribution happening,
in this case, between male and
female colleagues,
which is escalating very quickly.
How do they fix that?
>> Interesting.
Harsh attribution between male and
female colleagues.
So I'm just kind of thinking through this.
It sounds like it's an us
versus them problem.
We tend to see more harsh attributions
when people see people as others.
So it's a little hard to know without
knowing more about the situation,
but I think the core of the problem is
that there's some grouping going on.
And for some reason, there is the women
are feeling ostracized by the men or
vice versa and
that needs to be resolved in order for
these harsh attributions to diminish.
My guess is that for some reason, there
isn't a sense of psychological safety for
even the men or the women in this group,
so that might be something to talk about.
It might be worth having a conversation
about what it is that's going on and
there also potentially there could
be competition that's going on.
There might be a feeling of
powerlessness in one group or
the other that is leading to this.
So I would try to dig a little bit
deeper to investigate what the source is
of this division, this subgrouping
that's happening between the genders.
And sometimes,
it can actually be something in
the content of what you're working on.
For example, if the women are responsible
for a particular part of the project and
the men are responsible for
another particular part of the project.
That can set up this dynamic, as well.
>> And asking here for recommendations
on virtual team building exercises,
what are the some of the kinds of things
teens can do to build that trust?
>> Yeah, yeah.
So a lot of people, what they
want to do is get everybody together
in a neutral location for
a couple of days of team building.
I am actually not a fan of that at all.
If you've got a lot of money and
a lot of time, great.
Something to do, but I don't think it,
the half life is relatively
short of those activities.
And the reason the half life
is short is because you're not
getting at the core issues
that get in the way and
the court issues are really the work,
and how people do the work.
And when you're off team building,
that's not what people are doing.
You're getting to know one another.
You're understanding personalities and
so forth.
So it's good.
I'm not saying it's not a good thing,
but I'm a real advocate for
having people travel to
the location of the other site or
sites they're working with.
And not just the manager, but
the team members travel, so
that they can see the context in
which one another are working with
the example from Frankfurt where their
innovation approach is very different.
It's really good to go and
actually sit side-by-side and
see how people are working,
and who talks to them, and
what their office space looks like.
And what they do for lunch and
the cultural context in
which they're embedded.
That has a much more profound
effect on collaboration
going forward than team
building kinds of activities.
>> Great.
Thank you so much, Pamela.
We want to thank you for your time today.
We hope you enjoy the hour and
we encourage you to check out all of
our offerings at scpd.stanford.edu.
And again, don't forget that you'll be
receiving a recording of this webinar to
share with your friends and colleagues.
Have a great day.